HBO is officially making a Game of
Thrones prequel show about dunk and egg
called a knight of the Seven Kingdoms
Duncan egg is a series of three short
books about a knight and his Squire
adventuring in Westeros set 90 years
before the main Game of Thrones series
dunk and egg is small scale compared to
the main series there are no big battles
there's only a few characters but their
stories do involve Targaryen politics
magic and prophecy Author George Martin
previously said he wanted to write about
10 more Duncan egg stories to finish the
series before making a Duncan egg TV
show but now they're starting a show
anyway so like with Game of Thrones
they're adapting an unfinished book
series to TV but George is credited as a
writer and producer for this show and
House of the Dragon showrunner Ryan
condle is involved so hopefully it'll be
great it looks like season 1 will cover
the first book The Hedge Knight and ALT
shift X has made videos about all three
Duncan egg books so you can watch them
at the link below thanks